today I'm going to be speaking with
Jesse singer who is a journalist and
also author of the book there are no
accidents the deadly rise of injury and
disaster who profits and paid and who
pays the price uh Jesse great to have
you on I really appreciate it thank you
so much for having me David so you know
in the context of these the I'll start
with something kind of micro and then
we'll we'll go from there there's often
these stories of oh there was an
accident with a gun someone was shot it
was an accident a guy accidentally shot
his daughter while cleaning the gun or
something like this and we often will
talk about on the show where okay yes we
sort of understand socially what the
term accident means under the law this
is often called the negligent discharge
of a firearm and sometimes it is
something that people are charged with
and it's considered a crime at least in
theory but the term accident sometimes
puts like a very particular spin as it
may be on our understanding of sort of
like what happened you talk about this
at the corporate and the industrial and
and other levels talk a little bit about
what does it mean for something to be an
accident in the context of law and our
understanding of what took place to just
kind of get us into the discussion
yeah I mean it's a really tricky term in
that sense because you know you know it
means so many different things
and then has this specific legal
definition of the line between
intentional violence
um and maybe an act of God you know
someone who dies during a hurricane for
example totally out of our control and
it is a way of I found in the book
absolving certain people uh when things
go wrong and punishing others you know
and so we see
um really different outcomes depending
on who's shot in the case of an
accidental discharge you know who the
victim is
um and whose gun it was um and whether
or not we want to put blame on them as a
society and this even breaks down to the
smallest levels like if you look at
um people being killed by drivers in
like jaywalking crashes yes
um um or like drunk drunk driving
crashes in particular where someone's
you know struck by a driver the race of
the victim correlates with sentence
length so that if the person struck by a
drunk crossing the street by a drunk
driver is is black the sentence length
of the driver is significantly lower so
there isn't an area of accidental
so-called accidental death where
um you know we're not seeing huge
variations in how the term is understood
to
um
to you know kind of equate for different
punishments and then since so many of
these things are not individual acts of
human error but really predictable
preventable systemic causes we see the
least culpability when it comes to the
actual like corporate perpetrators of
these crimes you know and like how
the make and model of a gun and the
design of a gun and the way that the gun
has not been regulated is actually the
real problem here rather than whether or
not it went off when you were cleaning
it you know there's this book I read a
few months ago I think it's it must be
about 20 years old now it's called
normal accidents by a guy named Charles
perro I think is the pronunciation of
his last name and in the book he talks
about a lot of different areas he talks
about aircraft accidents he talks about
nuclear he all these different areas and
he kind of distinguishes what we might
call like systemic accidents which are
in a sense predictable where we might
say here is a system here are the
tolerances here are the ways the system
can fail and we can sort of make a
prediction as to how common these things
will be and it's not going to be zero
almost certainly it's not going to be
zero and one of the really interesting
things he writes about in the book is
that as you add mechanisms to try to
make a system them more safe the added
complexity and the fact that you now
have systems interacting can actually
keep the odds of an accident so-called
roughly the same or sometimes even even
kind of increase them we know that to
some degree these accidents are
predictable in systems because actuaries
in Insurance part of their job is to
sort of like put a monetary value and a
number on How likely are some of these
things to happen on this on the issue of
predictability and preventable when it
comes to industrial type stuff
we often will learn after the fact that
industry knew about a lot of these risks
very specifically and they either
minimized it covered it up whatever the
case may be what are the kind of counter
pressures that the public can sort of
exert or the tools that exist not after
the fact to do a class action lawsuit or
a mass tort but in the lead-up to these
systems sometimes failing and what does
you write about also are predictable
ways
absolutely yeah pero's like kind of the
one of the classics of this field who
really like gave us a framework for
understanding and one of the things I
try to do in the book is take perro's
basic ideas this normal accident Theory
um and by which he didn't mean uh normal
as in uh common but but predictable yes
um the inevitable you know consequence
of our systems and he meant that an
accident is a thing that exists in four
walls a nuclear power plant an oil
tanker this contained thing but
something I try and do is blow out that
theory to look at the much larger
systems we have that correlate directly
to accidents and that's income
inequality that's racism that's
corporate power and a lack of Union
power you know because we talk about
these things as random and if it was
true you know then injury related death
would be randomly distributed across the
country but it isn't true people of
color people living in poverty are most
at risk
um and what we see is that you know most
people who die in accidents don't die in
Charles pero's accidents you know a
nuclear meltdown right now ones and twos
every day on our roads in our homes and
in our workplaces and so to answer like
what the solution is at the core of it
is that these accidents where people of
color and people living in poverty are
most at risk are accidents where policy
and infrastructure make the difference
between life and death so the safety of
our homes homes the safety of our roads
the safety of our workplaces and that's
where we see these huge disparities in
accidental deaths so to name one black
people die in house fires at twice the
rate of white people
indigenous people are struck by cars at
twice the rate of white people so these
aren't you know um you know matters of
individual error these are matters of
different conditions that different
people are facing whether or not your
apartment is a fire trap and whether or
not your government is regulating your
apartment and holding your landlord to
account and so the Big Picture answer is
that you know
regulating corporate power and forcing
policy to protect everyone universally
primarily through government regulation
and access to the social safety net will
reduce the way that risk is currently
unequally distributed across the U.S it
seems there's also sort of like a
psychological component like if we think
about drug overdoses as an example
recently at his rallies Donald Trump has
been too much praise from the audience
talking about we should do the death
penalty for drug dealers they do it in
China quick trial 100 conviction rate
you know all sorts of authoritarian
dystopian nightmares but the crowd loves
it and they cheer and there is something
about when there's an individual here's
the guy on the corner who gave me the
drugs versus here's a pharmaceutical
company that uses sales reps to
encourage the over prescription which
then you get from a doctor filled by a
pharmacist the personal blame seems much
easier psychologically when it's the guy
on the corner to some degree and that's
probably much to the Delight of the big
Pharma companies and their lobbyists
right like that's by that's a feature
for them
yeah absolutely and I think you often
see you know today from Pharma companies
um but throughout the history of
accidental death whenever there's a rise
in one specific type of accidental death
you see corporations pushing these bad
people stories right
um and so you know you see it directly
I'm going to quote um one of the Purdue
Pharma leaders you know who was like you
know the problem here early in the
opioid epidemic is the criminal addicts
the abusers they're the problem not how
we're marketing an addictive drug is
non-addictive but these individuals and
that is deeply comforting for us as
people we are comforted and feel
permitted to move on from what seems
like random tragedy when we can find a
bad guy because it's a way for us all to
say
I wouldn't make those decisions I'm not
like that person that that person who
died that person who hurt someone a
nothing like them because they're bad
and when we Define them as bad we can
see ourselves as good as as smarter as
someone who will do a little better
under the same circumstances and this
ranges from you know accidental death
where we really do see a stigmatized bad
person like a person who's addicted to
drugs yeah but also when you know on the
little ones like a traffic crash or you
know a fire where a kid was playing with
matches finding the bad person you know
blaming the parent blaming the
jaywalking pedestrian is a way for us
all to say it can't happen to me I'd
make better decisions
um and we see throughout the history of
accidental death even all the way back
to the Industrial Revolution you know
when workers were dying and Untold
numbers and factories and coal mines we
see industrialists pushing this idea of
the accident-prone worker and this
caricature and stereotype of a drunk
immigrant who doesn't speak English
sloppy worker that was really the cause
of this massive accidental death toll
and in fact it was actually that the
factories and the coal mines were
incredibly dangerous and we know this
because when we start to regulate those
factories and coal mines accidental
death on the job plummets yes so
speaking of that I mean I think it's not
at all a one it's an all of the above
for me not a one of these things we have
ways in which regulation uh can make
things safer whatever it is those things
we're talking about are there's also
those who say
to different degrees technology is going
to dramatically improve these things as
we learn more about how to design roads
self-driving cars you know you have all
of these ideas that at some point
technology is going to make a lot of
things much safer technology and
factories that is going to reduce injury
for example the counter to that seems to
be that the new technology allows the
limits to be pushed for profit again so
like now you have sort of like the same
amount of safety but there's more profit
and more productivity and so you have to
know kind of how to counterbalance that
but to what degree is it fair to believe
that technology will be a factor in
making the world safer
you know so this is this is an old Story
and there's always been huge advances in
technology that have reduced the
accidental death toll but only under one
condition which is when they are
regulated and so if you look at
technology like seat belts airbags
collapsible steering columns these were
in the car huge advances in safety but
only once they were regulated into every
American Automobile and when they're not
when you have government regulatory
agencies that are afraid to regulate
like Nitsa is today we get into a
situation where rich people survive and
poor people die
um so like fully autonomous driverless
cars are a way off but there's a wealth
of life-saving technology that already
exists is tested and proven automatic
emergency braking intelligent assist
speed Governors that are regulated in
other countries where accidental death
is far lower but we don't mandate them
here cars are under regulated so only
the rich are protected the rich pay for
features that could say ever save
everyone's life if the government forced
it you know and we see the same thing
you know as far back as the Industrial
Revolution you know there were
Technologies a few companies were
putting them forth but the overall death
rates weren't falling because the
government wasn't forcing corporations
to account and when that happened we saw
results
last thing I want to talk about
um inevitably one could imagine this uh
kind of caricature of the over-regulated
nanny state where we take everything you
and I are talking about to the absolute
extreme and you know science fiction
movies are made about it and it's all
very very scary and to some degree I'm
like sort of joking about it but also I
think even people who are in favor of a
stronger regulatory infrastructure would
concede that there's some limit at which
we say well here are some choices we
simply allow people to make but we want
to limit the collateral damage that
might be associated with those choices
so it's really a choice that only
affects the person making the decision
how do we start to think about where on
the slider we sort of put that pin
between the idea of freedom and safety
or do you think that that is not even a
valid Spectrum for discussion
I think it is a notably
um uh new Spectrum it's a discussion
that I think we spend a little too much
time on and we're talking about more
than 200 000 people every year in the US
that are dying completely preventable
deaths and those numbers are infinitely
lower in other wealthy countries the
rate of accidental death is so much
higher here because we have this
rhetorical conversation about freedom
but when it comes down to it I think the
nanny state is wonderful if you don't
want to die in early death I mean what's
a nanny it's someone that rich people
pay to protect their children from Death
we should all have that
uh Americans will respond to what our
leaders promote this country did not
start to reject the protections of a
benevolent government like on its own
it's a product of corporate propaganda
sold through the mouthpiece of
anti-government anti-regulatory
presidents and that's been happening for
decades I don't think Americans want to
die horrible painful early deaths in the
name of Freedom we just need politicians
brave enough to protect people and to
tell a better story than this
anti-government anti-regulatory
propaganda that we've been sold yeah
crying about a nanny State often is a
way
to kind of invalidate conversations
about just reasonable regulations that
that should exist it's sort of a way to
kind of clamp down on debates it's kind
of similar to
I'm offended I'm oh well okay the
conversation's over then I guess it's a
similar cudgel in a sense
yeah absolutely and it leaves us in this
place where people die
preventable deaths
deaths ones and twos and we all tell a
story about personal responsibility and
the fact that maybe they were bad people
um even though they're simply
protectable we're not going to fix human
error we're not going to make people
perfect but there are so many ways we
could protect them from harm that we are
disregarding for a conversation about
freedom in the nanny State and the need
for personal responsibility Jesse last
thing lowest hanging fruit in terms of
preventable death that could be improved
relatively simply or easily we know what
to do what are the areas that people may
or may not know about where the numbers
are high and could be lowered
dramatically
it's true in every area of accidental
death by simply empowering our
Regulatory Agencies so people are better
protected and Reviving the social safety
nets so people can afford to better
protect themselves you know not drive an
old car take the most dangerous job live
in a fire truck apartment
um and because accidental death is so
broad there are a million ways to do it
in your community you can advocate for
traffic calming and public transit
expansions because you're far less
likely to die or to kill someone if
you're riding the bus than you are if
you're in your own car you can fight for
safe injection sites and the free
distribution of naloxone which directly
dramatically reduces accidental overdose
deaths pushing for Ada accessibility
accessibility like ramps and grab bars
you know in your workplace and in your
apartment building is going to reduce
accidental death making sure fire safety
regulations are on the books and
enforced sprinklers self-closing doors
all this stuff it doesn't you know
reduce the likelihood hood of you making
a mistake or a kid playing with fire or
someone not being a distracted driver
just reduces the likelihood that it's
going to kill anyone it just protects
people
we have been talking with Jesse singer
who is a journalist and also author of
the book there are no accidents the
deadly rise of injury and disaster who
profits and who pays the price Jesse
really appreciate your time today thanks
so much for having me David